[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: Marvel's Avengers is
a third person action adventure
game featuring an all new
original story where you
play as your favorite Avengers.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The story starts on A day
at the opening celebration
of the Avengers west
coast headquarters
and the reveal of the team's
new tarragon crystal reactor.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
But after being blamed for
a disastrous explosion that
leaves San Francisco
in ruins, the Avengers
are forced to disband
due to public backlash
and government pressure.
In their absence,
a new organization
rises vowing to protect the
world, Advanced Idea Mechanics,
otherwise known as AIM.
Five years later, the world
is a very different place.
In their pursuit of a safer
future through science,
AIM has replaced
superhumans with
their advanced synthoid AI.
That was the question.
NARRATOR: But under
the surface, the signs
of a conspiracy against
heroes begins to unfold.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
With all Super Heroes
outlawed, an Avengers fan girl
from New Jersey named Kamala
Khan embarks on a quest
to prove her heroes'
innocence and become
who she was destined to be.
Kamala plays a central
role as the catalyst
to reassemble the team
with her unique perspective
and incredible powers.
Only together can
the Avengers overcome
the dangers in this new world.
You'll start by establishing
a base of operations
in a decommissioned
helicarrier, which gets
upgraded throughout the story.
You can customize your heroes
to play solo or assemble
online with your
friends defending earth
from ever escalating threats.
Each of the heroes has
tons of outfits inspired
by over 80 years
of Marvel history,
as well as original new ones.
As you play, you'll
earn an unlock gear,
equip different gear pieces
to customize your playstyle
and become even more powerful.
Power up gear by unlocking
perks which will change
the way you play the game.
Unlock skills and abilities
as you earn experience
and build your heroes
to fit your playstyle.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Using the war table,
you can launch into two
different types of missions.
Hero missions are the single
player campaign experiences
showcasing specific heroes.
And war zone missions,
which are played
solo or online with up to
a total of four players.
All missions drive
the narrative forward.
And all of your
heroes progress is
shared across the entire game.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Reassemble the Avengers and
rebuild the team to be Earth's
Mightiest Heroes once again.